let's bring in Andrew Brandt the Monday
Morning Quarterback columnist former
front office executive let me ask you
that question I'll start with that
Andrew what's the position that you
wouldn't want it knowing what you get
paid and the prestige that goes along
with it what's the worst position in the
NFL yeah good morning Dan and I think
it's got to be the business approach
which is my expertise and it's got to be
running back it's the shortest shelf
life in the NFL they're the most
disadvantaged by this college
eligibility rule of three years in
college before you can come out because
they're prime earning years are when
they're in college and of course their
first contract which we're going to talk
about a minute and by the time they get
to the second contract a lot of teams
are like yeah you know they're kind of
washed up and we can get one in the low
rounds and the only guys paid relief now
or McCaffrey and bail on the franchise
tag last year it's like yeah it's a bad
position if you're talking about the
business of football and I said at the
time look if Carolina needs to have
somebody you want to come out and watch
then pay Christian McCaffrey you're not
going anywhere with that team for the
next couple of years
Dallas invested in Zeke Elliott and then
they gave him the contract extension
which I wouldn't have done but you know
Jerry Jerry believes in hey we we have a
good running attack I don't know what
the Giants are gonna do was say Quan
Barkley at that position handicapped
that down the road where we are with the
NFL with these running backs
I don't first of all is a running back
gonna be taken in the top ten anytime
soon and are you going to extend these
running backs that you take in the first
round yeah I mean I guess from a
personnel standpoint there's always
those outliers like Elliott like Barkley
like McCaffrey that are going to be top
10 picks maybe one every two years I
mean I think that's where we're really
talking about but on the pay scale
listen I hear about the outliers Frank
Gore Emmitt Smith Curtis Martin but
that's what they are they're outliers
you know and we got a league that
doesn't like to admit it but people in
my former position are all in analytics
right now all into modeling and
statistical analysis and quants and
Harvard PhDs in the back of the offices
and they're telling
don't pay running backs I mean just
don't pay him when you talk about
allocation of resources you know the
positions quarterback pass rusher left
tackle but at the bottom of that he's
running back and that's my answer that's
the bottom position so they're gonna be
some tough decisions you got a guy like
Aaron Jones who had a great year for the
Packers you see my helmet yeah what they
do they draft a running back in the
second so this is happening all over the
leaf well if you could have Christian
McCaffrey or Jamaal Adams mmm that would
you want let's say pay is the same yeah
I mean obviously is gonna contradict
what it just you know I think there's a
guy he's truly special but in McCaffrey
but there's there so few of them and and
and segwaying you're right damn Safety's
kind of back there on the list to safety
linebacker you know these are the
positions that traditionally don't get
paid now I know what Adams are saying
what his agents gonna say they're
special they're the McCaffrey and
Eliot's of that world but again teams
are looking at and say okay where are my
resources quarterback you know they're
gonna have to paid Arnold in a couple
year or a year and then pass rusher and
then of course left tackle and offensive
line and you've got a GM there whose
history is pay the trenches as he didn't
Philadelphia pay the trenches that Lane
Johnson's the Fletcher Cox's you know
and then from there look outside the
situation with Jamal Adams where he is
he wants to get a new contract here but
does he have any options here what does
he have any leverage I mean the short
answer is no I think some teams are a
little more it's a hard word you know
like cowed by this kind of thing but I
think in recent years less and less
teams I mean I think back to the Jets
years ago that were cowed by the civil
disobedience of Darrelle Revis and
responded but I don't think there's much
going around right now that has that and
as I tweeted this morning Adams has no
leverage contractually he did a
five-year rookie contract what's
for years plus an option and as we know
their tags beyond that so right now the
Jets have two years of contract control
plus any tags and how do you have
leverage there I mean how do you have
leverage and as you indicated before the
break if he tries to extend this to take
it to another level with a holdout oh my
god I mean the CBA already rolled back
rookie contracts and you know the kind
of contract control teams have but now
they added penalties severe for holdouts
we're talking to Andrew Brant the Monday
Morning Quarterback columnist former
front office executive if Jamaal Adams
called you for advice today what would
you tell him is there a way to have
reasonable contract negotiations now
rather than play on this contract for
two years because I think once you get
to trade demands then you're not talking
then it's kind of like baseball then
you're just kind of in the corners you
know you know can we get to a contract
and not have him sit for two years
waiting for that to happen now Jamal
Adams I would be the agent I would
understand you'd have to take below
market because you're too weird years
away whatever the top of the free-agent
safety market is they were free agents
they didn't have two years left so you
got to balance that versus his talent
versus whoever those players are what
are the Cowboys waiting for with that
Prescott or what is dak Prescott waiting
for I'm going to take a different view
here I said this one being your show
before dak Prescott not only has
leverage but his leverage increases if
he waits now Kenny wait because V Wade
sends the second tagging do they really
want to do that and then he's
negotiating with extreme leverage but
maybe that's the play that CAA is using
with the Cowboys like we want to really
knock it out of the park homerun and if
you don't want to do a homerun Cowboys
will wait oh it's it's kind of that
simple and you know I think mahomes I
think Chiefs are gonna throw a ton of
money at him and he can say great or he
can say I'll wait and my leverage will
only go up
and so with Prescott he's what he you
know people can mock 40 million a year
whatever he wants but why not
what's his downside play for 25 this
year
okay the business of bringing in colin
kaepernick we know the political aspect
of this but the business side of this
tell me why you would or wouldn't bring
in Kaepernick if you were running a team
well I wouldn't because it just seems so
reactionary you haven't done it for four
years no one's been eager to do it at
before you talk about Goodell
encouraging teams to sign I mean I would
if I'm an owner I'd encourage people to
stay out of what I was gonna say what
does that mean that the commissioners
encouraging owners to do this I mean
they're they probably look at Roger and
say Roger shut up you know we run this
and no one has quote/unquote endorsed
his statement which is another issue to
in itself about protests but I just
think if Kaepernick the other issue with
Kaepernick that's been there all along
Dan is backup players have been there
for an office you don't want backup
players getting a lot of attention
frankly you know you'll you got a star
quarterback it's a lot of attention off
the field time you know but a backup
player and obviously he's gonna be
backup
he hasn't played in three years and what
team is gonna say forget all the
politics well this guy what player in
the league right now is coming off three
years of inactivity zero we had dr.
fountian yesterday and he's talked about
maybe the NFL needs a bubble like the
NBA your thoughts on the bubble for the
NFL well it's interesting because we've
seen comments from doctor sills of the
NFL doctor mayor of the NFL PA and the
translation bin of those conferences
thanks doc we'll handle it because they
don't want to go in the bowl they don't
want to put 53 +20 coaches plus 50 staff
in a bubble now they do do a bubble on
Saturday night and Sunday before the
game and they're in there but no I mean
listen this is a big issue because we've
been here 10 years with concussions
what's the stated priority of the NFL
health and safety of our players now
here's the reality if that's true they
wouldn't play right yeah if that's their
number one priority yeah they wouldn't
play but it's not true because the
business of sports because the economics
say you really have to play and you have
to play and whatever modifications you
have to do but if you start drilling
down here's the problem you got a
hundred and fifty pages about social
distancing and not spitting or sneezing
or locker room six
but it's football you know how do you
practice and play football
among these protocols that's the needle
that they're trying to thread here you
can do all you want with 115 pages of
protocols but I don't know if any of
them go into playing the game practicing
which is the opposite of social
distancing it's you know bodily contact
and sweat and droplets everywhere so
that's I don't know how you saw that
yeah I saw where Sean McVeigh was
basically saying that he goes I don't I
don't know how you can be safe but then
play football it John Harbaugh said I
just don't know how this is possible
here and I wondered Harbaugh's jump
articles talking about the protocols
which is great I mean listen you got to
do it sorry John it's it's impossible to
live like that but you got it but it but
the McBay thing is more realistic Slyke
what about timing
no and when you have a coach saying that
that's an issue so listen the NFL has
been extremely fortunate they can watch
basketball they can watch hockey they
can watch it with baseball comes back
they can watch MLS how they do how they
do with testing and treatment and
tracing what did they do what's best
practices for isolating and quarantine
they're so lucky because of the time but
then you get to the fundamental question
of can they actually play this game
where the virus is gonna be in three
months they're hoping it's much less
than it is now but that hope is not a
plan good to talk to you Andrew
hope you're well thanks for joining us
always a pleasure Dan that's Andrew
Brandt Monday Morning Quarterback
columnist